the Joe Rogan experience yeah and then
he's wrong
yeah he's very strong and there is it's
very cool to watch and yeah and when
when butter come when the when the the
speaker called bother re and he comes in
him the mood is just you know
everybody's you can see the flash of
many phones in the audience great it's
very crazy feeling when when but I
verified he's the most famous yeah
famous in the mission he's a legend and
he's not just a legend because of his
fighting which is mean he's been an
incredible fighter but also just cuz
he's so crazy yeah he's always get in
trouble yeah that's right that people
love by the road because of the fighter
yeah but also because of the bad boy
yeah it's funny fighters that get in
trouble in Conor McGregor's been in a
bunch of trouble lately yeah you know
some people are upset at them and some
people are not and it's just it's not
good you know everything's not good but
he's a wild man wild man do wild [ __ ]
yeah not good to smack that guy at the
bar though I watched that again I
thought it was like a touch last time I
talked about I thought he'd just sort of
touched him in the head was hand I saw
the video looks like almost like a punch
yeah almost like a buzz yeah he hit him
I misspoke I thought he just I basically
thought he just touched him in the face
no cuz I watched it on my phone and it
just wasn't that clear no and I watched
on the computer I was like what does he
do you do that I don't know maybe the
guy said something really bad to him but
wouldn't you know just big star so huge
doesn't but he's although the wild [ __ ]
like grabbing that guy's phone and
stomping on it I saw them he's just a
little too crazy just a little too crazy
sometime I didn't notice that maybe it
was drunk I don't know probably knows
yeah I can say nothing about this yeah
yeah maybe was drunk that's what I told
first I was like he was drunk to me but
me and your team may control you you
know your guy may got you yeah right
if you offer a man at a bar a drink and
he doesn't want it and you punch him in
the head he's definitely making some
mistakes but I love my personal fight
it's a wild dude it's amazing how many
fans he has - I've never seen anything
like it why don't ya early on is that
you early on in his career before he was
a champion remember after the fight yeah
when you when you slept guys your name
keep you keep it but the problem with
him is gonna be guys like khabib and he
wants a rematch with khabib do you think
he could be kind of fired could be
[ __ ] him up yeah why would he fight
him again that's right I think the money
fight yeah I think the money fight for
him is Nate Nate Nate again that's a big
fight but Nate they're talking about
Nate fighting miles Badal
you know the fights Jorge Masvidal I
think that fight is that's a huge fight
as well and you know Conor may or may
not ever fight again like who knows he
says he's going to but I think yeah
maybe maybe poor you just yeah maybe but
poor yeas got a fight could be yeah you
know I mean that's next month that's
that's the big fight yeah right and
khabib is the big I mean Cubs the only
one undefeated in the division his
wrestling is [ __ ] terrifying he gets
people on the ground
I see [ __ ] out of them I assume work at
a K it was just crazy
Kobe's yeah he started studying a combo
spot when he was when he was kid yeah
it's very yeah you ever see how they
play basketball little Harris my friend
who's will Harris production she's been
in here before as well he filmed these
guys playing basketball I was watching
that podcast and then after that video I
just went to the future to watch the
video you was talking about and yeah the
basketball crazy it's crazy the West
gets a guy in a rear naked choke and the
guy you can't even tap like the whole
thing is so like they're they're hard
people and they are hard people I I
watch the poster girl it was talking
about he went there to film a beer
yes it wasn't yeah well what wills very
talented will Harris he does a great job
of capturing these guys stories yeah and
put in he's a nice guy people like him
so they're they're loose and relaxed
around and he's very talented as a
filmmaker so when he puts these these
pieces together they're very impactful
and that theme is on the YouTube yes yes
all the stuff is on YouTube what is this
Conor McGregor to face for Mayweather in
Japan what is today that so this is I
just looked up his name so I brought it
up there's a game show they supposedly
have assigned to be on where they're
gonna compete against each other and
this says he signed or he's going to
sign for a reported ten million dollars
to do it do a game shot on contact so
Winchell like break contract or anything
so he didn't get that much money for
that like 10 million bucks for a game so
well they paid Floyd nine million
dollars to fight that uh the yeah he's
supposed to be part of that too yeah
intention yeah yeah yeah
Naz Okawa who's a bad [ __ ] but
he's tiny yes so small yeah and a lot of
people thought that that fight was fixed
with him and Floyd I was like no like
even good [ __ ] good like fight
commentators thought that was fake I was
like watch it again let's watch it again
Tom first Runk dude wait 20 pounds he
fights a hundred and 26 pounds Floyd
beat the [ __ ] out of him
he's so much bigger Floyd was so loose
he just was just clubbed him in the head
this is that clearly when you fight
freely mérida you must train like like
you ever do that they didn't even give
him enough chance like the boy was a
couple of months yes yeah well you
didn't have to get in shape for that guy
look Boyd is way bigger than him way
bigger
I mean Floyd's not a big man yes way
bigger than tension tension is tiny
he's a tiny we look as but against those
other 120 pound guys he flunks those
guys up yeah he's very good very even in
kickboxing yes very interesting yeah he
does like wild [ __ ] like weird spinning
kick yeah like Japanese fight a very
good like a second Oreos one of my
favorite fighter in Japan yes and when
twins brothers or yerba Co Yahoo Robbie
the other guy Illinois it's damaging to
tensions legacy because everybody
thought he was a joke
after Floyd that's what I thought not
even if he left foot if Floyd let him
kick it would be a different fight
that's what I was hoping I was hoping
they were talking about a fight I was
like it's gonna be a kickboxing fight
like me Floyd be so crazy there is a go
ahead and kick let's see what's up yeah
of course